[Music]
we always love seeing with our favorite
characters from the loud house are
wearing while they usually wear the same
clothes every now and then the animators
spice it up keep watching to find out
our favorite loud house outfit one more
awesome videos click subscribe to keep
up with all our amazing content now
let's check out the ten loud house
costumes that are better than the
originals Laurie's winter outfits the
oldest loud sister is always so stylish
she looks so put together while we do
love her normal look of brown shorts and
a blue tank Laurie's winter outfit is so
cute she wears this outfit in several
episodes whenever the weather calls for
it instead of her white pearl earrings
Laurie wears chic white earmuffs she has
replaced her blue tank with a pale blue
winter jacket that white trim really
takes it to the next level her purple
pants are so cute they are either
leggings or skinny pants because Laurie
is always up with the latest fashion
these are tucked into blue boots that
match her coat how cute is this ensemble
fancy LuAnn the Dobbs family's comedian
is usually seen looking a little
ridiculous she wears a white and yellow
outfit with a squirting flower like a
clown she did graduate clown Academy
after all in the episode head poets
anxiety we find out that LuAnn actually
cleans up pretty nicely she mentors Lucy
in the arts and Lucy gets a chance to
perform her poem at the Royal woods
theater Lucy dresses up for the event
she wears a long yellow gown she puts
her hair half up in a bun with a yellow
tie and did she borrow those pro
earrings from Laurie she is still Luanne
though because she's got that squirt
flower pinned to her dress is it just us
or does she remind you of Belle from
Beauty and the Beast Lissa prepares for
battle the second-youngest loud sister
isn't exactly concerned with the fashion
she's a super genius and the smartest
member of the loud family you poor
fragile homosapiens she usually looks
like a cross between Velma and Shaggy
from scooby-doo but every now and then
she changes up her look in April Fool's
rules the whole family tries to avoid
the vicious pranks Luanne always plays
Lissa builds a bomb shelter to protect
herself and
she dresses the part she dresses like a
world war ii soldier with a green helmet
and supplies strapped on her back it's
too funny Lisa can be so dramatic
Lucy in love lucy is often seen creeping
around and popping up unexpectedly she's
the black sheep of the family and she
dresses like it normally lucy is the
epitome of god she loves wearing black
and it's a good look on earth but when
she develops a crush on rocky in back in
black her sisters decide to give her a
makeover we mean several makeovers her
sisters dress her like a cheerleader and
des Princes and more but our favorite
look was the total 80s outfit she's got
the big hair and an off-the-shoulder
animal for its shirt her black capris
are spiced up with pink accessories it
may not be authentic Luci but it's a
pretty great look
Caribbean Luna Luna the rock-and-roll
queen of the loud family always dresses
so great she wears a purple Punk
schoolgirl outfit most of the time but
in the episode linkers swim she changes
a perv I've to something a bit more
relaxed as she plays the steel drums she
is dressed in a Rasta inspired purple
outfit she's got a skull t-shirt with
her shorts but she adds cool sunglasses
and a yellow beanie she's having a
really good time man we love that this
Alfred is different from normal but it
still feels authentic to Luna lend the
rock star as the loud family's most
athletic and competitive member Lynn is
almost always seen wearing athletic
clothes sometimes she changes into other
outfits based on the sport she is
playing but very rarely dresses like
anything else but in the episode yes man
she reveals her love of smooch that's
the famous rock band she and the other
sisters put on a concert for Lincoln and
Lynne wears a purple and black outfit
check out those spikes on her shoulders
she also looks fierce AF with that red
paint around her eyes if you think this
outfit is epic stay tuned to find out
our favorite loud house outfit amateur
and Lincoln no loud house lists would be
complete without including Lincoln the
only boy in the loud family and the
start of the show is usually seen
dressed in an orange shirt and blue
jeans but whenever he wants to dress up
he cleaned up pretty nice Lincoln's
light blue suit is his
grown up suit he thinks it makes him
look older and more mature and he's
right the orange tie is a nice addition
and it's just so Lincoln he also combs
his white hair down whenever he wears
his suit he looks pretty spiffy Lola the
mermaid
Lola loud is pretty convinced she is
actually a princess she is a pageant
queen and she loves everything pink and
girly she is usually dressed in a long
pink pageant gown with a tiara but she
can't wear that to swim in a few
episodes we see Lola's swimsuit or swim
gown as she calls it it's pink of course
and it totally makes her look like a
mermaid the frills resemble scales we
guess she's a mermaid princess because
she never takes off that tiara Lana in a
dress Lola's twin Lana is the total
opposite of girly she's a tomboy she is
usually wearing overalls in a baseball
cap it matches her personality perfectly
because she's always fixing things and
getting messy but in a toddler's tale
Lana gets forced into a dress
Lola manipulates all her siblings into
doing things for her she puts Lola in a
frilly teal dress Lola insists on a
tiara which Lana wears on top of her
baseball cap she even wears jewelry
it's so not Lana and she's not very
happy with the ensemble it's hilarious
to see her looking so different a very
Lenny Christmas mini lav may not be the
smartest sibling but she's definitely
the most stylish she has some mad
fashion design skills and we've loved
seeing her in different outfits her
fashion game is always on point in 11
mouths 11 she wears several Christmas
outfits and they are all so cute we love
the dress made from Rita's Christmas
tablecloth only Lenny could pull that
off she also makes a cute Santa inspired
dress from the family stockings forget
what I was wearing before this is a
perfect Christmas outfit but our
favorite is her white tinsel dress
there's so much holiday spirit in it
we love the ornament earrings and the
red bow belt which extra loud outfit is
your favorite let us know in the
comments and those are the loud house
outfits that are better than the
original give this video a big thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe
see you next time
[Music]